that is my impersonation of
despicable me part 2.
despicable me 2. the word despicable is
never used once
in this movie not one person goes
despicable me and you know what i kind
of like that how a character doesn't say
a line
that could be used in the movie this is
a family film honestly
really wasn't looking forward to it too
much it looked like it had nothing to do
with groot
i felt like it was about the minions
being silly the whole time
so i watched this movie and let me tell
you how i felt
it was a delight i had a great
[ __ ] time you know that phrase you
always hear on the trailers it's fun for
the whole family this film is literally
fun for the whole family
i cannot make a sucking a dick joke
because this is such a good family film
that i respected to not talk about
this mouth being on a penis i actually
watched this movie
annoyed by the minions before i saw them
and they're like my favorite [ __ ]
thing in this whole entire movie i love
these little guys look at them
they're just so adorable you wish they
were real you want to own
one you want to have a bunch of them
i want children one day and then you got
gru played by steve carrell
law i am group that sounds more like
borat than it does
grew but you know you know what i was
going for and that's what counts in this
film
i actually enjoyed grew way more don't
get me wrong i thought he was great in
the first one but in this one
he's just really lovable right from the
beginning and you know what they didn't
just rehash his character
they actually gave him like character
development and a new journey to come
you know in the first one he has to
learn about
himself and love himself in this one he
has to learn to love
some of our supporting characters such
as kristen wiig's
character whose name i do not know agent
wilde i think is what it is and you know
what
she is really fun to watch in most
movies they would just make like that
character
the secret agent person who's like got
you know wears all like black leather
and has all the gear and they're cooler
than the main character but they made
her like really
wacky really funny but still really cool
at the same time
and it was fun to see a character be
that way and she's beautiful to look at
i wish she was real i'd ask her out on a
date
might even do some things with her
if you know what i mean
sex there's also some other great
supporting characters you know benjamin
bratt
brat plays like this this this mexican
guy who owns a
restaurant for mexican people and he's
fat and i heard al pacino was supposed
to be this guy before
i don't know what al pacino's problem
was supposedly he had creative
differences
why would he do righteous kill 88
minutes
and play himself in jack and jill but
when it comes to despicable me 2
i got problems i don't like it the
minions too much they remind me of
little jews running around and also too
the directing in this is pretty [ __ ]
awesome the tone and the shots and it
was all very very good what i love about
this film is it's a comedy it's one of
those rare cartoons that doesn't just
have humor in it no this one was a flat
out comedy and it's hilarious at times
there's stuff that's hilarious for kids
adults might not laugh at there were
times where everyone was laughing and i
was just like
but then there were also times where i
was like
comedy it's great to see a movie where
it's you know really just does have this
heart and it you know has drama at the
right moment so there's also some really
cool action there's there's so much
going for this film and the animation
is perfect the animation is absolutely
superb i [ __ ] loved it
if you don't love it well there's
something wrong with you maybe you're
face blind
so yeah you know pretty much in this
movie everything worked
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say despicable me 2
got it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below
and tell me what did did you hear that
dog
and if you want to go ahead click this
link to follow me on twitter and yes i
will follow you back
because i'm that kind of guy and if you
want to see more in-depth review
of despicable me 2 go ahead and check
out my show called
reasons to see that i do my buddy jerry
got special guest on the show michelle
she's mexican
mexican there's a lot of mexicans in
despicable me too
it was like white people and mexicans
there was a lot of mexicans in the movie
and there's nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong we have a mexican on the
show and last but not least if you want
to get updated every time one of my
reviews or video is out
go ahead and click on this button by my
crotch to subscribe
right there where the crotch is
where it's not so despicable